en el que en varios lugares de siria se
ha regulado ese principio entonces la
revolución es que hay que recordar que
hoy se cumplen 10 años no de la guerra
sino de aquellas protestas que surgieron
para pedir por nuevos cambios en el país
el gobierno de bachar al asad respondió
con extremada violencia oiga han querido
los activistas recordar a miles de
muertos tanto es de 500 mil personas que
han muerto durante esta guerra
esta mañana donde habían especialmente
activistas de la provincia de empleo que
están cuando
las fuerzas rebeldes de los grupos
extremistas cuyos dueños
de esta mañana tenían a la comunidad
internacional
esta revolución que ellos no estaban con
ningún grupo terrorista sino que sus
demandas
y que se les escucha